[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
super excited to be talking about AI and
satellite imagery we have Lister joining
us on the show hello hi great to be here
thanks so much for coming on and I'm
really grateful to Lisa for introducing
us yeah that's you you guys were just in
the hall coming down knocking on the
door and we're just like yeah we'd love
to talk about satellite imagery that's
such an awesome field and looking at
your room I can tell we are super into
satellite imagery gives that macro
perspective and we're gonna be unpacking
this and a lot of depth let's give Liz's
background she's the co-founder and CEO
of similarity which uses AI to analyze
satellite imagery and you can find more
information on similarity comm as well
simulated comm for such block which has
more examples greater detail and also
the twitter is below as well Liz let's
start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world I I think we're going to be
understanding our world a whole lot
better than we do now we are putting
sensors everywhere and the amount of
satellite imagery is is growing at an
astronomical rate pardon the pun but
they're launching more and more
satellites and the data is is becoming a
big flood of data because a lot of the
analysis has been historical same thing
with sensors if you've got sensors in a
manufacturing plant you've got guys who
who listen to the sounds of the machines
make and go oh it just went cathode it
doesn't usually do that so as we add
more sensors we get a much better
understanding of what's going on in our
world and I think seeing it from above
we get a better understanding of things
that we really had no chance of seeing
any other way yeah on our
the human level perspective there's the
macro the micro the molecules atoms and
then there's the macro the cosmic
perspective so yeah to be able to have
the insight and like you said the data
flows are crazy I think it's somewhere
around ninety percent of all data credo
screen in the last two years and it just
keeps happening just keeps happening
exactly to be able to analyze it and
make sense of it not only the internet
interwebs and the Internet of Things but
also all the satellite imagery and like
you said there's so many satellites
going up and it's everything from those
little bread loaf planetlab satellites
to the Big E called it mainframe one
you're now seeing outside of the the
visible light spectrum yeah exactly so
it's when people think of satellite
imagery they usually think of pictures
you know the RGB pictures that look like
the pictures that we look at but
satellite satellites are now getting
more and more sensors onboard that look
at things other than the visible
spectrum and there's an awful lot we can
tell based on these multi spectral
sensors on these satellites and we're
getting more and more radar based
satellites that can actually shine a
light in the dark to illuminate what
you're looking for and it does that
during the day as well but now we can
see in the dark and now we can see
through clouds to see what's going on
with synthetic aperture radar yeah we're
gonna be unpacking that in a bit because
it's yeah what a cool innovation a
see-through clouds yet now I see outside
a visible light spectrum whoa whoa let's
do journey but you're analyzing we're
making use of it you know you're moving
its value yes
so jumping into the journey how did you
become who you are today we'll heard
where'd you pick up your interest teach
us about you
so from
early age I was great at math and I
there wasn't a whole lot of
discouragement of girls in math at that
time so you know I got put in advanced
classes I had a great time with it and
when I got to college my dad wanted me
to study engineering because he's an
engineer and so I'm like okay but when I
took my first computer science course
I'm like this is beautiful you tell it
what to do and it doesn't it's so much
more straightforward than the real world
so I really fell in love with the beauty
of numbers and the you know just the
utter simplicity and and the ability to
actually direct and control creating
something where you know you don't have
to worry about hurting people's feelings
and all these other things if you're
working on something more concrete so
but truth be told in college I was
interested in meeting guys and smart
guys and so I hung out at the computer
lab and then I realized that they were
talking about stuff I didn't know and
I'm like okay I gotta fix this an
embarrassing origin story and then it
was asking to learn and teaching that
I'm kind of like yeah yeah well at that
point I was more of an engineer than a
computer scientist but I was just
fascinated about computer science and
the things that they were talking about
and I'm like okay I'm going this way
sorry dad no civil engineering doing the
computer science thing yeah intelligence
is very attractive the sapiosexual
attracted to be so much more yeah the
application of the intelligence into the
real world like yeah such a critical
part and Mike my co-founder and I Ray
Richardson he has a degree in
theoretical computing
and he went to school for this got the
Institute for man and machine
exploration and so he he started writing
space oriented programs did some work at
the JPL operated the operating system on
the Mars rover so he's got a lot of this
background and is super intelligent but
doesn't do the business and the people
part and so I've got a computer science
background my degrees in computer
science engineering but I do the
forward-facing part yes and then how did
it go from being fastened with computer
science to what was it about a decade or
more until you started similarity oh it
was quite a lot two decades and so those
constant work in the computer science so
software that style of yeah mostly
application software application
software and as I was working in
application software I started to see
the data tsunami and realizing we don't
have good tools that handle this we we
just don't and that really was the
inspiration to go out and build this
it's a great way to put a data tsunami I
wish I could claim that too so we set
out to build artificial intelligence
programs that could make sense of all
this data and we started in retail
because I was working at a retail
company at the time but we built it from
massive scale because we were trying to
solve this data problem and at the time
and this goes back more than eight years
when we started this there wasn't so
much data it was just peachy
you know just starting to take off but
it turned out building an AI that can
scale tremendously to you know hundreds
of nodes and be able to to analyze large
amounts of data has a lot of
applications
yeah so okay so then you were first
starting in retail doing some of this
making sense of the data tsunami okay
and so then you were like I like making
sense of the data its we can learn so
much you know with AI we've discovered
like thousands of new species because it
can go through and and look at samples
you know in the water or in the wildlife
and find things that we've never found
so there's so much more we can learn
about this world and that's what really
excites me oh yeah yeah Wow yeah the
computational capacity like you were
saying to be able to say oh do this and
that's done through the computer yeah
versus having a in the physical world of
humans it could be can be a lot
different
so then how about the moment for you
where you were you wanted to start with
similarity how did that start so I've
known my co-founder Richardson for more
than 30 years I met him in college and
we went different ways for a while and
then we came back together and we were
constantly talking about you know how
how we can improve the world what we
could do and I told him you know at work
I've got this problem one got way too
much data and I'd like to make some
sense of it and he says I know how to do
that so that's kind of where it started
and we got married oh wow
congratulations well thank you and we
just passed ten years of being together
and working together every day on this
kind of stuff and we love it yes that's
great yeah you guys can work together on
us on a passion project yeah yeah that's
super important yeah that's like two
minds on the same exactly
and he's like I love so much that you
can actually understand what I'm saying
so we basically do design together and I
do a lot of the gathering of the
customer input and kind of say okay this
is what we need to build and he goes off
and figures out how to build it
and so okay this has been eight years of
welding this that's okay this is a while
so since 2011 yes okay well let me
actually started before 2011 and then I
went in full-time in 2011 because we had
a product yeah so it was two years of
nights and weekends hmm uh before I
actually went full-time on this so it's
been a long time yeah and there were a
lot less satellite images in 2000 unless
satellites in general and now there's
more they're only going to be more so
applications like this into the space
economy are very exciting it's great
huge growth over time and and the that
geo intelligence community is screaming
out for better tools to automate because
that took the tools that they have now
assume that it's a single person I'm
working in front of a computer that's
doing the analysis and looking for the
changes and there's no way that you can
keep up with what's going on I mean we
talked to a very large company who uses
satellite imagery to analyze their
remote locations and it took them a
quarter they would get imagery quarterly
and have this whole fleet of analysts
spend an entire quarter looking at it to
determine what was going on is like this
isn't gonna scale you know did you see
the change in this area of pixels over
there over the four month period well
exactly that's that's way too late to
actually do something about it generally
so being able to to see the imagery more
frequently there's at least one company
that's imaging the planet every day well
yeah the whole planet the whole planet
a fleet of satellites yes yeah Wow bad
we call them constellations
constellations yeah the constellations
of satellites yes yes and then an
everyday image to a certain resolution
right they're constrained by resolution
still exactly okay because the the
constellations each one is easier to
produce but that's because you don't
have the resolution of this super
expensive cameras that need a lot more
power and it it it can be really
challenging but come countries around
the world and we're seeing a lot of this
being sponsored by countries are
launching their own satellites and in
some cases putting them in
geosynchronous orbit over their country
so that they can keep a better eye on
the country most of the satellites kind
of roll around the earth and map it that
way
so if you're in low Earth orbit is that
like within 250 miles oh yes there's
about a 90 minute orbital period okay
and then that's like the International
Space Station has at that orbital period
and then geosynchronous is like 400
miles developing out and then would
geosynchronous you can actually keep it
orbiting with the Earth's spin on its
axis so we can literally just be looking
at one location and just constantly be
looking at that location right wow
that's great well yeah and there's only
more to come right so going back to your
original question I really think that
this is the age of learning so much more
about our world and I can't wait to see
where it takes us
and the way medical technology is
changing we might be around to see some
of the really interesting stuff that
comes out yeah yeah yeah totally of the
to be able to see how how civilization
does in the next couple decades hundred
years okay we have some awesome slides
and images to share so okay similarities
using AI SAR so SAR was the aperture say
say that a synthetic aperture radar
synthetic aperture radar which lets us
look through clouds and do 3d modeling
of buildings and and basically the radar
itself is a source of light and so we
can look at things at night because it's
supplying its own light and regular
imagery and multispectral imagery we use
the Sun as a light source yes yes okay
so when when the half of the earth does
not get sunlight and there are
satellites on that half of the earth
then if they have satellite aperture so
that synthetic aperture radar yeah and
there's a good explanation of that in
our blog and your blog and then they can
they can provide the light on that on
the dark side or her for being able to
image it yeah from the actual satellite
it provides all right yeah and it
doesn't take that much energy for this
satellite to do that why it's not cheap
so it probably does take some energy to
do that and what they're doing is is
shining a radar beam onto the earth and
measuring the reflectance as the
frequencies come back and based on the
variation in the reflectances it can
produce imagery based on what they do is
they can send out horizontal or
vertically polarized light and then can
get back different horizontal and
vertical polarized light and be able to
create an image of that image all that
okay
and then optical imagery find the
unusual the invisible in the heart to
find okay cool
you guys are based out of point Richmond
or on the on the East Bay Avenue space
great okay so and you guys have a
YouTube channel to just know they're a
good thing youtube.com slash similarity
check that out of great videos there
yeah great videos okay so I think some
of the important things that we're going
to talk about in here are the the most
important things probably the exact use
cases of it so right now a lot of
military movements smugglers rebel camps
illegal shipping the valuable insights
that we can get from other aspects of
how our climate is changing
yeah these types of things deforestation
is a big one for station okay so manual
analysis you spoke to that earlier about
how it's really hard to have teams of
analysts just looking at an image that's
changed after three month period when
the data flows are so great
exactly so to be able to have something
like your software being able to parse
it and if you're trying to stop
smugglers or stop deforestation you need
to be able to tell that it's happening
now and send people out right finding
out that you know you lost ten thousand
hectares over the last four months not
so useful we know it happen now go
tackle it yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
interesting that there's something
illegal happening that there's a some
sort of human trafficking or antiquity
trafficking or whatever happening that
what about poachers can you spot a
poacher killing a rhino or an elephant
and then shoot a laser beam down that
last part everything about it you just
can't say hey stop what you're doing
yeah but the laser being part yeah you
probably need a UAV for that I don't
think the laser beams from the satellite
are going to work but we do analyze UAV
images too I can work on that for you
yeah just hire Iran for making the laser
destruction anything okay so you but
then you also can take a UAV okay
exactly so these and that's on unarmed
aerial vehicle on a manned unmanned
drones unmanned aerial vehicle yeah
drones and then they fly at about the
commercial airliner yeah yeah I mean
they can go up and down but yeah they're
there in that airspace and you can get
super amazing resolution using the UAVs
but it obviously takes a lot longer
because they're small and you've got to
go back and forth to cover an area okay
yeah okay so then so then you also take
images from UAVs we do we can actually
cool any kind of geo-located imagery and
with the UAVs they know where they are
and that information gets passed into
the imagery so we can actually do
something that nobody else is doing and
line up images of different resolutions
to look at a historical context from the
the images of super-high resolution like
you get from a UAV to super low of
resolution like you get from some of the
flee the free satellites that are out
there and put them all together and our
software can resolve that and look for
differences in this major set of images
because one of the problems that's
happening right now there's one company
imaging the earth every day there's
another that's trying but they're doing
it in different resolution and then some
of the higher resolution satellites will
come every two days or every three days
and if you're looking at you know a
tropical country if it's covered with
clouds they skip that place a lot so
being able to get a better understanding
of what's actually going on you've got
to come up with a set of images that are
all relevant for the place you're
studying
and then you know stretch or shrink them
so that they can stack on top of each
other and we can look for anomalies okay
okay so then you can have UAVs just a
couple miles up versus the 200 miles up
I'm getting potentially greater
resolution you can stack those images on
top so we'll get to the that historical
context on the so a I ABS mm-hmm
automated image anomaly detection system
okay that's okay that's a cool acronym
so you're looking for the anomalies in
this historical context that we're about
to show exactly okay cool
and you can take input from satellites
or drones then you run it through the
automated image and amelie detection
system and then on the output you share
the anomaly files you send notifications
to people and that's usually the
providers and the AI in AI 80s it stands
for automated image but it also stands
for artificial intelligence and that's
where we're building our predictive
models yes yes okay cool and then this
is this is like really the beautiful
image that I'm super excited for you to
explain great
so typically change detection looks at
two different images and basically
subtracts one from the other to show you
what's different what we do is look at
historical images and create a
predictive model of what it should be so
here we've got four images November
January April and May of this same area
now we got a new image let's pretend
here and we want to know how does that
compare to the historical images are
there any differences in here that I
should be looking at and based on the
predictive model that we've come up with
here we highlight these changes in red
and so this image is basically just the
anomaly heat map laid over the current
image here with the red parts
highlighting exactly what has changed
yes but you can see here the color of
the grass the grass changes yes
the reflections change and we learned
that all that is normal change and we're
not going to bother anybody look in it
Brown grass that used to be green yeah
yeah this is crazy how do you how do you
know if it's a change like you can tell
here that that that these have changed
quite a bit between these two the
earlier images and then the candidate
image that you're using to compare it to
and you can see it's also made a change
over here right so this is where the red
is on your on your heat map how do you
know if it's you know grass changing
colors or I mean you're gonna give the
example later where a tunnel was dug
right it's like how do you know that
it's just a different color of brown
versus if something's happening yeah so
this is where the analysts come in and
the the geospatial analysts need these
tools to highlight what this is and then
they go in and look and say oh my god
that's an airstrip they've got a lot of
expertise in understanding what the heck
it is that we're looking at so what
we're doing is calling attention to the
things that are important to look at
daughter they did the analysis to figure
out you know is that a school bus or a
tanker or a pickup truck full of rebels
Wow okay
correct great okay so this is also
similar to the medical industry as well
where we're looking at all the bodily
scans and that it's it's like a flag
that happens and then the we still use a
physician's an analyst the medical
analyst to say okay this flag was yes
great great catch okay so then so then
you're using the Geo's analysts that are
still looking at the red and the red
anomaly heat maps and they're saying
what exactly sometimes there are
instances where it's like I know we
think that may just be something but
that that looks like a new parking lot a
new parking lot okay
okay we can tell some of those things
and one of the interesting things about
parking lots are if you've got an active
parking lot at a mall or something like
that we learned that having cars in that
park
that is totally normal so even if it's
different colored cars on different days
we don't flag those as anomalies yes if
there's a parking lot that's usually
empty and then there's cars in it
oh yeah like that as an anomaly so this
historical context gives you the ability
to see things that you wouldn't have
necessarily noticed or anomalies it's
just like oh that's just cars but if
there didn't used to be cars there that
means something and then can explain the
RGB side of this yeah yeah I use our GB
to basically refer to the visual
spectrum using images that that we can
see in red green and blue like we see on
our monitors yes and the visual spectrum
is actually just a small piece of the
electromagnetic spectrum and different
parts of the electromagnetic spectrum
have different frequencies and a lot of
what we measure here the way cameras
work and this works is you shine a light
on something in measure what's coming
back and that's the same with the
different electromagnetic frequencies as
you can shine that on something and look
at what's coming back and make some
determinations based from that and if
you've got a sort of a wide number of
multi spectral bands that there are
indices out there they're basically math
between the reflectance and the bands
they can tell you this is asphalt this
is a palm tree there's metal that we
detected here it's being used for mining
it's it's being used for a lot of things
because different things reflect
differently at different bands in the
spectrum interesting and so we're
learning so much more and if you're
really curious about what's going on
somewhere you can find out through this
combination of multispectral imagery and
visual imagery
and we use the multispectral imagery in
the anomaly detection and so we've seen
images where two factories they look
exactly alike in the visual spectrum but
one is is giving off some kind of gas
that's invisible in the visible spectrum
but shows up very brightly and the multi
spectral analysis that we do well and so
it's really cool okay so then we have
the normal on the electromagnetic
spectrum we have the normal visible
light that we're using to analyze and
then we also have the multi spectrum
everything all down to infrared all the
way up to to get gamma and that's ray
yeah yeah so so you're see er you're
then able to take all both of those the
visible light in the multispectral and
analyze that as well
Wow okay and then and then the the okay
so that you gave that example which was
really interesting about like gas coming
out from a factory that's a really
interesting one that you can't Sarah
lessee with visible light it's a pretty
cool and and then also it's another
probably interesting one for visible
light would be that when you see those
ten thousand hectares so four is just
gone you need to call someone in like
before ten thousand disappears yeah yeah
go and investigate what is happening
exactly our one of our clients lives in
a place where there's a lot of illegal
deforestation going on and
that people doing the illegal for
station are heavily armed once they know
they're doing illegal activity right and
that people are going to try and stop
them and so it's not necessarily a
simple problem of going up and say hey
stop chopping down those trees it can
actually be fairly dangerous yes so
being able to know where they are when
what they're doing when they're moving
it it gives the the police or whoever is
working on solving these problems the
the intelligence they need to know to be
able to go in and stop it without
getting slaughtered yeah yeah those
insights are huge now is the
multispectral analysis also then able
like you were saying a little bit ago
that that there's a certain way that
metals reflect differently yeah then you
can actually do things like see where
the metal is in the forest to see where
the yeah they are
so one of the one of the problems that
we're working on addressing and we have
a prototype of now that's looking really
good but it's not public ready is
finding human activity enforce canopy
under forest canopy a lot of bad guys
hide out in the forest and do their
smuggling or drug making or whatever it
is somewhere away from prying eyes we
want to be able to find that and so if
you take a visual image you get trees
yeah yeah if the canopy of trees exactly
you can't really tell much at all with
multispectral you can tell the health of
the trees you can tell if somebody's
been you know burning fires and damaging
leaves things like that with
multispectral but with SAR it can
actually penetrate the canopy
and find reflectance off of metal
objects so that guys can have a lot of
metal objects yeah
damn and then so then also for like
mining and for other uses as well bent
that you can see with multispectral you
can see the way that other metals are
moving yes and if you know particular
surfaces are rich in certain kinds of
metals Oh interesting the surface yeah
yeah their richness yeah but and another
example in mining is watching how the
earth around where the mining is
happening is behaving and being able to
detect cave-ins
for example because SAR can be
incredibly accurate you can use a thing
called interferometry which measures the
interference that's coming back and that
can be really quite precise and telling
you changes about the earth and it's
we're not doing interferometry yet but
that's kind of one of the next things
because it's such a great source of
information if you're looking at the
surface of the earth or other things
where they are being deformed and you
want to see what's happening okay
Oh interesting so potentially seamless
sea levels changing yeah or you know
subside in slike Islands sinking Islands
sinking that type of stuff yeah yeah
okay cool cool cool interfer
interferometry yes interesting okay
okay okay cool I loved I love this this
example so great and it's it's totally
speaks to being able to use AI apply to
historical context to analyze all that
yeah but watch what we're actually doing
there is creating a predictive model for
every single pixel and there are
hundreds of thousands maybe hundreds of
millions of pixels in some of these
images so we use that computing power to
do something that seems kind of crazy a
predictive model for every pixel so
you're you're you're saying okay well
it's looked like this this looked like
this holy cow it's changed a lot and
it's not what we predicted it looked
like so yeah yeah because sometimes with
seasons too you can start predicting
that it's gonna look like this over a
span of a year and so if it's changes at
any point over that you're not something
that's not familiar right you create a
predictive model for every pixel that's
crazy it is crazy yeah and it couldn't
be done without the cloud computing
capacity that's available today yeah
thank goodness for cloud computing
capacity yeah yeah so but then but then
what's nice is you can take an area like
this and say that okay well this whole
chunk of pixels is is gonna have a
pretty similar predictive model yeah
yeah cuz it's all green it's all like
that okay and this is all buildings it's
all gonna look about like that okay okay
cool all right all right so you we kind
of we kind of unpacked this and this is
you all so you kind of spoke about this
as well next yeah okay great great okay
and so this I'm really excited about
this is what we've got prototypes right
now is not only are we finding metals in
the woods but if we're looking for rebel
camps they typically cook on an open
fire hmm they generally don't have any
vehicles they generally move in single
file their marching if they're moving we
can create rules that apply to is this a
rebel camp
and then use the data that we're getting
out of the imagery right DBC mental
reflected did we see something you know
damage to the trees from the open fire
cooking right and with a rule set put
all that together and say this is
probably a rebel camp or this is
probably a school yeah right I important
another difference yes yes whoa so this
is cool so you can then start setting
them the parameters as well and saying
that okay well we are seeing if you see
these three things then likely it is
this and so they can get that a faster
parsing of the data but and we can
provide more insight somewhere in sight
yeah provide more insight faster so you
know we talked about the analyst having
to figure out whether that's a parking
letter and I as we are able to develop
more rules to apply to what we're
looking at we're going to be able to
help them even further yeah in no way
are we but placing analysts you just
want to make that clear and same thing
with the physicians in medical industry
yeah yeah we still need them yeah yeah
yeah
it's augmenting augmenting the work yes
yes okay so this is synthetic aperture
radar seeing the hidden yeah peruse
pacaya-samiria national reserve yeah and
this one is from NASA JPL with UAB SAR
so they're actually flying SAR on a
drone for this picture but what we're
seeing in this forest here if if you
just looked at the visible spectrum it
would look like trees and vegetation but
what we're seeing here is some of this
vegetation is inundated with water so
the dark green is low vegetation that
could be floating the pink and red are
different types of inundated vegetation
inundated with too much water Wow
and then here is have a flood or some it
could be could be a fish could be if
somebody could be way over watering
their crops I'd yeah but and then the
the grayish-green is tropical forests
and so sorry see how these different
things are reflecting and can tell you
basically what's going on with this
foliage this vegetation that you
wouldn't be able to see any other way
and it's it seems as though than the
importance of something like this is
like can you can you see things you'd
like you said in the earlier you see
seeing the hit it yeah I see it again
the very beginning that's very cool
then also just are you then looking at
the the water levels that are that have
how do you know it's inundated the
plants and the crops how do you how can
you tell with SAR that it's done that so
just like there are indices in
multispectral imagery that tell you
what's going on
people who study sour imageries create
these index indices to tell you if
you're seeing this in the reflectance
pattern that you're getting back it
means it's an undated vegetation in in
the reflectance patterns that you're
getting back so the radar go is at night
if you do anything you can go during the
day to and then depending on the
reflectance pattern that you get back
yes how you can predict that exactly
there's so much technicality that I
still want to unpack but we'll have to
do that on another sit down together to
get into the nuance about how that
actually works on a technical side okay
and this was really interesting okay
teach us about NDVI right so NDVI
normalized difference vegetation index
is a very standard index that's used
across the industry but it's a great
demonstration of how using multispectral
imagery can give you information so
we've got three images here one is just
a visual spectrum RGB image
that doesn't look like much in fact it's
maybe even hard to tell that there's
crops there yeah it does look hard it
looks like the crops were already
harvested in that yeah or dirt or
something dirty yeah yeah when you look
at it in just the near-infrared band you
can start to see detail crops yeah okay
when you combine the near-infrared band
with some other bands you for this NDVI
index what you're getting here now is a
very clear picture of the crops and
healthy crops reflect differently than
unhealthy ones
Oh interesting and so a common gradient
is red green where red is unhealthy
crops and green is healthy crops so the
the fact that what we see is this but
the electromagnetic spectrum can help us
see this and make determination about
the crops really super useful and it's
it's stuff that we can't see with our
own eyes unless we create things like
this so you're doing the multi spectral
analysis and you're also kind of you're
combining different multi spectral
analysis yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and we
do anomaly detection on this so let's
say this is a candidate image we can use
historical images and then compare the
NDVI over time yeah yeah yeah create the
predictive model they're so cool in in
all of these cases we can look at the
historical context see how things are
changing and flag unusual changes as
long as you have a historical context of
an NDVI image over time which is well
that's a lot of data again it's a it's
it's it needs to be a multispectral
image that you can calculate NDVI from
yeah there are a lot of those and people
are building more but it's not that
image the planet every day kind so then
you'll get mostly RGB images for our
satellite imagery for now and then
multispectral imagery is coming in hot
and there's a lot of data coming in that
and then you can from that you can make
historical context of of an NDVI as well
as an RGB so then you can analyze on
different yeah yeah and NDVI is just one
of maybe hundreds of different indices
that can tell you there are hundreds of
different yeah indices for imagery yeah
that can predict pavement you know
identify pavement certain metals it can
even see through some of the water and
look at things like coastal erosion and
stuff like that so there's really an
amazing amount of stuff and so we take
that data build predictive models around
it and they can say it looks like your
crops are dying or something like that
well you know they used to be healthy
but then you started watering them too
much in July and another water logged in
don't looks of it mm-hmm this so it
takes me all the way back to what you
said at the beginning where you're just
like we're gonna we have some image data
so many sensors we're gonna just know so
much more about the planet that we live
yeah yeah okay and then most of the
clients are using you guys as a SAS we
do both okay um the on-premise software
is essentially being used by classified
clients okay and that means like
military yeah okay and then are there
also companies that like that use it for
like are there are there can you can you
is there like a like a normal fortune
500 company that uses it as well for
some of their basic needs so there are
other companies that provide analysis
for fortune 500 companies that do things
for their basic needs the cart Labs is
really good we call justice what we're
really helping them do is make the
analysts more efficient yes and yes
correct in a in a classified context
that really matters an awful lot and
they get way more imagery than anybody
else right we have friends that analyze
imagery for four different governmental
organizations and that they have that as
something that that they literally get
so much of so many images and to be able
to have something like you saying look
at this with our historical context
these are the areas to specifically look
at don't waste your time on and that
actually brings up an interesting origin
story okay yes please
so the origin story we were we were
focusing on change detection you know
building these predictive models and
detect detecting changes and anomalies
and we captured the attention of a Saudi
Arabian prince who wanted to bring that
technology into his country and he's
sort of a tech savvy guy and so there's
a handful of companies that he's brought
into Saudi Arabia and one of the other
come companies happened to be there at
the same time we were there and had had
a sales call that had not been too
inspiring and Jamie our contact said we
get this call where we're in the bedroom
it's like 11 o'clock at night in this
hotel in Riyadh and he's like come down
to the lobby I've got a great idea
Wow so he introduced us to this other
company who shall remain nameless
and their problem was the the generals
and the people in the in the military
we're saying we can't analyze the stuff
we get now you know we don't have time
to go through all this stuff I'm not
gonna buy all your imagery cuz I'll have
anybody to look at now don't have the
time unless you can come up with some
sort of automated way to help us you
know identify this imagery and what we
need to look at I'm not buying your
stuff yes and we went wait a minute we
could do that yeah we could totally do
that and that's where it started
I love that that's such a good one is
that yeah at the moment of someone's
saying yeah make making the life easier
of fur analysts where where's the
pointer where should we look
exactly yeah yeah okay and you know
client and partner list of course we
kind of went over some of these already
but specifically we're about to get to
an interesting example with tunneling
I'm excited to show that one yeah okay
but this is oh this is one more of what
a classical yeah yeah yeah this is this
is like there's so much yellow where am
I supposed to look exactly this is a
change detection result where you're
just looking at two images and those two
images can vary a lot in ways that are
not important and this actually is our
anomaly heat map on top of the same area
and what it found here is a new roof and
you can see it here and you can see it
really clearly here yeah there's that
difference and so lots faster to figure
out what happened yeah yeah yeah because
that other one was just looked like a
cloud like this one just looks like a
cloud of yellow and it's so hard to be
able to pick stuff and then when you
come to this one you find very quickly
that that's the new hot the new roof and
that
that's great and you know new roofs
might sound fairly mundane but there's
an enormous amount of illegal
construction that happens all over the
world and whose plot of land is that and
you know doing okay bad control exactly
maybe they got a permit for a one-story
building and they built a three-story
building and didn't build it to code
right because a lot of you illegal
construction not necessarily built to
code why would they
so finding illegal construction and
making sure it gets up to code or it
gets taken down or the owner you know
pays appropriate property taxes a really
compelling use case for cities and
municipalities that are trying to you
know get a hold of this yes yes and then
this example is also so so crazy so this
is the Israeli Defense Forces long left
that they've been looking and have found
this is the fourth Hezbollah
cross-border terror tunnel that they've
found and they're not using our software
yet but the entrance was found near
Romney yeah and here's an illustration
of that and what we're gonna do is look
at the site where the the digging
happened yeah yes so this is the West
Romney aware there's those who called it
a tunnel terror tunnel right which is
crazy that you can bear go right under a
wall that's constructed and to be able
to use something like this to detect
that exactly so there that blue line was
the border and you could see that it
crossed under the border so here are two
pictures an earlier picture and a more
recent picture of that area that the
tunnel entrance was actually found
in the wooded area that's crazy that was
found there yeah and the thing that
showed up to us that may that gave us a
hint that there was something going on
and there's no way that an eye I think
could catch this so easily no there's a
big pile of dirt here yeah and if we go
back back you can see the big pile of
dirt but it's pretty subtle when you're
looking at all else around and so
there's a dark it looks like dark brown
with some in here but this looks like
freshly dug up dirt and then when you go
to the next image your anomaly exactly
saying look at that yeah yeah and if
you're digging a tunnel you're moving
dirt and it has to go somewhere
yeah and so something like this is a
really good clue that illegal activity
may be happening and if you don't
discover that tunnel for a couple of
years you're gonna wonder how is it that
people are getting into the oh yeah yeah
so oh yeah yeah yeah your tunnels under
borders are big problems yeah let's get
to that world peace everyone well it all
depends on what side you're on let's get
to that world peace as soon as possible
peace don't count on em okay and then
that's a crazy example and then here's
one last example and this was the was
this the same gas leak no different
different okay okay but what these are
are oil storage tanks and oil storage
tanks actually have floating roofs so if
there's a lot of oil in there that the
roof will be higher and you won't be
seeing so many shadows mm-hmm if there's
not a lot of oil in there the roof is
lower and you can see more shadows and
there is a company that actually
specializes in analyzing the shadows to
determine how much inventory is there
whoa whoa that's not us yeah what we're
looking for are unusual things
and here what we found was what appears
to be a leak in this particular roof you
can see how it looks different from
these other roofs and we highlight that
here as you've got a problem with this
one which I think unless you were on top
of it you really wouldn't see a
detection of an oil leak yeah yeah whoa
yeah there's whoa the amount of like
applicable cases I mean we went through
so many in this conversation but and you
have a very fascinating way of doing the
detection with the historical context
and doing the anomaly detection I think
that's so interesting yeah yeah and it
really does speed up analysis and that's
what we're hoping for is is to help the
folks who are protecting us the people
who are trying to get anything done help
them understand what's happening yeah
there was a big fraud case in Mexico a
few years back where people were
investing in this gated community type
construction and it was totally fake and
what because if you're outside of Mexico
and they're sending you updates
everything's going great you you're
thinking okay I'm gonna have a condo and
when you look at it from the air there
is nothing there there's nothing being
built yeah oh wow so you can actually
observe like construction companies and
like that are developers yeah see if
that's true what they're exactly and
companies have development projects
going on all over the world big
companies do and being able to keep an
eye on all of them is something you know
that you can now do remotely yeah yeah
yeah especially when it could be that
the funds are just being taken and and I
ran with instead of actually building
but yeah this is the whole trust thing
how many have they previously developed
how what on timeliness and I've been
able to develop them on let me satisfy
thousands of homeowners do they have
first off but now you can find out if
they're you know not doing what they're
supposed to be doing them yeah yeah
before we close I'd like to tell you
about one of my research use cases okay
so we've all heard of the Pacific
Garbage Patch yes and it's floating
plastic in a gyre in the Pacific Ocean
and it can't be seen from space because
the plastic particles are generally
fairly tiny I mean you'll see big hunks
you know here and there but it's not
like a giant floating trash island right
it's just where a bunch of trash kind of
accumulates the the actual large pieces
can be kilometers apart okay so what we
want to be able to do with SAR that can
at least penetrate the surface of the
water and see a different reflection
from plastic particles versus what might
normally be in the ocean we want to be
able to map and and track the Pacific
Garbage Patch and I think there's six
other Garbage Patch jars on the world
Wow and if you can measure it then you
can tell if you can make it better yeah
right if right now we only have guesses
as to how big the Pacific Garbage Patch
is and we know that it kind of moves
seasonally and and we're trying there's
a number of companies trying to do
something about it but we can't tell how
effective they are unless we can
actually measure what's going on fine
what's going on measure the size of the
patch the density of the plastic and see
if it's shrinking or growing and if the
mitigating things that people are doing
is actually helping yes yes and so I
think that without being able to deserve
it
observe it you can't tell if what you're
doing is making any difference yeah yeah
and that's such a good way to put it
it's to measure it gives you the
observational analysis which gives you
the ability to see if the things that
you're doing to try and augment it make
it better are working or not and that
can be applied to deforestation or
glacial melting or all different types
of military purposes is it working or
what is well by observing and measuring
it or weed yeah that's great
you saw for the Pacific Garbage Patch
and for all the other ones yeah it's
critical we need a clean match up yeah
we absolutely do and we should be able
to track sources as well if we're
looking at the entire ocean we can see
garbage plastic coming from different
locations well that's interesting to
which countries are contributing most
garbage patches should they then be the
ones most responsible for it yeah that's
yeah that's good and it's gonna be hard
to clean up because the particles are
really small the particles are small
they've broken down and they saw
whatever broken them down so yeah it's a
big problem then we eat them in our fish
weight yeah yeah we do
they found a plastic bag at the bottom
of the Mariana Trench
they found a plastic bag at the bottom
of the Mariana Trench that's so bad
because that's like five seven miles
yeah there's plastic down there it's
heartbreaking it really is so how the
hell did it get all the way down there
yeah
yeah it's heartbreaking it's time to
clean that [ __ ] up yeah yeah Liz this
has been so interesting and we're super
excited for what simulator keeps
building because this is like you said
we're getting that macro perspective
we're getting the context that we need
the observations that we need and we're
excited to you know to sit down again
and get an update on what's been what's
continuing to be built from you guys we
have a couple quick questions that we
like asking our guests on the show okay
okay first question is are we alone in
the cosmos I don't see how we could
possibly be alone I I really don't you
know from the Carl Sagan perspective of
there's so many planets out there it
just seems highly unlikely to a fair
amount of unexplained incidents being
well-documented by scientists I I
definitely think there's out there
things out there that we don't know very
much about and then the next question is
are we in a simulation simulation that's
a really good question
my co-founder array believes that we are
deeply believe the simulation and she
talked to her through that well yeah and
you know he's the one with the AI
background and we're like but the cosmos
is so big how could that possibly be a
simulation and he says well you don't
actually have to calculate all that you
only have to render what's exactly so
he's like it totally could be possible
there weren't a simulation yeah I'll be
fun to talk to Ray about it let's make
that happen that's a good yeah a great
idea and then the last question is what
do you think's the most beautiful thing
in the world
so that's a really interesting thing I'm
going to come at it from it the way I
respond emotionally rather than you know
a physical beauty or symmetry or
whatever and quite honestly I think the
most beautiful thing in the world is my
two dogs snoring and sleeping
comfortably on my bed and why I they
seem so content and happy and just
listening to those little snuffly snores
it it really it's one of those spark joy
things that I find really beautiful and
emotionally satisfying for the creatures
on the planet to be able to live in that
peace and happiness contentment yeah
yeah a number of people in my family are
vegetarians and I haven't eaten beef or
pork in 35 years
so I try not to eat things with feelings
and I'm learning that chicken and fish
have feelings so I'm gonna have to alter
my diet but yeah we have the clean meat
revolution coming we do which is very
exciting indistinguishable we do meet
yep I'm really excited for that and it's
gonna help us a lot with our conscious
as well when we're looking 50 years
later the kids will be like what the
[ __ ] were you doing slaughtering
billions of animals and so yeah yeah
well but we didn't have the technology
and I actually I learned something that
was a bit uncomfortable for me
evolutionarily speaking we are only
humans because we started eating meat so
most of the primates eat
vegetation you can't get enough energy
to power a large brain from eating
vegetation you just can't you spend most
of your day chewing exactly and our
ancient ancestors started eating meat
and got more energy so that their brains
could grow instead of fire as well
exactly yeah exactly and they got the
protein and the fats and everything
because our brains take up an enormous
amount of energy and so we would not be
human without eating meat it's kind of
interesting it is it is and now we have
choices yeah and we've the clean me
revolution coming yeah Liz thank you so
much for coming on the show this has
been a pleasure thank you huge shout out
to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing thank you very much thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode I check out the links to
similarity calm also their blog and
their Twitter as well check out all
those links below go and have more
conversations with your friends your
family or coworkers online on social
media get talking about AI and satellite
imagery and the importance of this
subject for the macro perspective of our
world and support the artists the
entrepreneurs the organizations that you
believe in around the world support
simulation our links are below help us
continuing to scale and impact more
people and go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon peace
[Music]